102557. The number had been on his left arm since the war, since the concentration camps, his three years in Auschwitz. And one day, a couple of years ago, living in New York City, it occurred to him, 102557, the number given to him by the Nazis, he could play the lottery with it.
102557。这个数字自战争、自集中营、自他在奥斯威辛度过的三年以来，就一直刻在他的左臂上。大约两年前的一天，当他住在纽约市时，他突然想到，102557，这个纳粹给他的号码，或许可以拿来买彩票。
Well, yeah, when it came to lottery, I sometimes played the number, but I gave it up, because it came to my mind, I said I shouldn't do this.
嗯，是的，提到彩票时，我有时会玩这个号码，但我放弃了，因为我转念一想，觉得自己不该这样做。
Did you ever win?
你中过奖吗？
No.
没有。
No. Never won any money on that number?
没有。那个号码从来没让你赢过钱吗？
No.
没有。
But you decided you shouldn't do it.
但你决定你不应该这么做。
No.
不。
How come?
为什么？
Because I think that I should not remind myself of this whole thing.
因为我觉得我不应该提醒自己想起这一切。
When something terrible happens to you, in the moment of crisis, it's rare that you can meditate over what it means. When Jan Tomare was in the concentration camps, when he was sent to work in the German coal mines, when he was selected for experimental surgery by the Germans, he didn't have bad dreams then, he says.
当你遭遇可怕的事情，在危机时刻，你很少能去思考它意味着什么。当简·托马雷在集中营里，当他被派往德国煤矿工作，当他被选中接受德国人的实验性手术时，他说他那时并没有做噩梦。
No. You were just looking to get food and stuff like that. You're just looking at how it's going to be, what happened in the morning. And as I am getting older, I'm more and more haunted by my past and the fate of my family, crying almost every night. I mean, I can't do anything about it anymore. So I try to be busy. I try to read book. I try to make anything, to do anything, to forget. I read papers. I read books. I read everything.
没有。你只是在想办法找点吃的之类的。你只是在看日子会怎么过，明天会发生什么。随着年龄增长，我越来越被过去和家人的命运所困扰，几乎每晚都在哭。我是说，我对此已经无能为力了。所以我尽量让自己忙起来。我尝试读书。我尝试做点什么，做任何事情，来忘记。我读报纸。我读书。我什么都读。
About the present, not about the past, you mean.
你是说关于现在，而不是关于过去。
Yeah.
是的。
What memories come back? Sometimes, Jan says, he'll remember a holiday meal, some small happy memory of his family, who died in the gas chambers. But that's rare. Mostly it's the bad moments which come back. And among those, the one he returns to more than any other moment, is the day in May of 1942, when his family was rounded up by the Germans and arrested.
什么样的记忆会浮现？简说，有时他会想起节日大餐，想起家人的一点小小的幸福回忆，而他们都死在毒气室里了。但这很罕见。大多是那些痛苦的时刻又回来了。而在这些时刻中，他比任何时刻都更常回到那个日子——1942年5月的一天，他的家人被德国人围捕并逮捕的那一天。
The whole thing was, back then, we were all taken to this place, [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]. And this came, and they took my family, my little brother. He was a little genius. And my sister. And they put them in those big commercial wagons, where they used to ship cows and then everything.
当时的情况是，我们都被带到了这个地方，[无法辨认的短语]。然后他们来了，带走了我的家人，我那年幼的弟弟。他是个小天才。还有我的妹妹。他们把他们塞进那些常用来装牛的商业大车里，装满了所有东西。
It was the last time he saw his sister, his little brother, his mother, his stepfather, a moment that, no matter how many times you look at it, never makes sense. One minute, your life is one thing, small, private, the next it's something else, thrown about by forces so much bigger. You're seized from your normal and pinned in the beam of history.
那是他最后一次见到妹妹、弟弟、母亲和继父，这是一个无论你回看多少遍都无法理解的时刻。前一分钟，你的生活还是原来的样子，渺小而私密，后一分钟，它就变成了别的东西，被远比你强大的力量抛来抛去。你从平静的日常中被攫走，被钉在了历史的光束之下。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Pinned in History, stories of people who were lifted out of everyday life, thrown into much bigger events, and how that made sense of what they did years after the fact.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“钉在历史中”，讲述那些被从日常生活中提炼出来、抛入更宏大事件中的人们的故事，以及这如何让他们在多年后理清了自己的所作所为。
Act One, Book of Job, a man who betrayed his friends, and then betrayed the people who he betrayed his friends for. Act Two, God of War, how a guy with one year of psychology graduate school got put in a position to decide who would stay at the front lines in Vietnam and who could go home, and what he did with that power, a power he never wanted, and what he makes of all of it now. Stay with us.
第一幕，《约伯记》，一个背叛朋友，然后又背叛了那些为了他而背叛朋友的人的男人。第二幕，《战神》，一个只有一年心理学研究生学历的人，是如何被安排在一个决定越南前线谁留下、谁回家的位置上的；以及他如何行使那项他从未渴望过的权力，还有他现在对这一切的看法。请继续收听。
Act One. So it's one thing if your life is thrown about by forces beyond your control. It's another if you go out of your way to insert yourself into history, and hurt people, and ruin other people's lives as part of that. How do you make sense of events for which you only have yourself to blame? Scott Carrier has this first story.
第一幕。如果你的生活被超出你控制的力量抛来抛去，那是一回事。如果你特意将自己强加于历史之中，伤害他人，并以此毁掉别人的生活，那又是另一回事。对于那些只能怪罪自己的事件，你该如何理解？斯科特·卡里尔带来了第一个故事。
February 17, 1957 was the worst day of Harvey Matusow's life. At 2:30 in the morning, his mother called to say that his father had died. At 8:30, his boss called to tell him not to come into work, that he was fired. At 11:30, his wife called from California, saying she was close to Mexico and that she wanted a divorce. Then at 2:30 in the afternoon, Harvey's lawyer called to say that the Circuit Court of Appeals in New York had turned down his appeal, and that he'd be going to a federal penitentiary for five years.
1957年2月17日是哈维·马图索一生中最糟糕的一天。凌晨2:30，母亲打来电话说父亲去世了。8:30，老板打来电话叫他别去上班了，他被解雇了。11:30，妻子从加州打来电话，说她快到墨西哥了，想要离婚。接着下午2:30，哈维的律师打来电话，说纽约巡回上诉法院驳回了他的上诉，他将被送进联邦监狱服刑五年。
You know what Harvey did?
你知道哈维做了什么吗？
I laughed. I couldn't stop laughing. People were coming to my mother's house to pay respects, to get ready for the funeral, and there I was laughing. And a friend of mine said, read the book of Job. And I read the book of Job that night and I continued to laugh. And I took on the name Job that day. And I've identified with him ever since.
我笑了。我笑个不停。人们来到我母亲家吊唁，准备葬礼，而我却在那里大笑。我的一位朋友说，去读读《约伯记》。那天晚上我读了《约伯记》，然后继续笑。从那天起我给自己取名约伯。从那时起，我就一直将自己与他联系在一起。
Job Matusow, born a Jew in the Bronx. Job Matusow, ready to die a Mormon in Glenwood, Utah. Job Matusow, liberator of Europe. Job Matusow, Communist. Job Matusow, who turned and became a paid informant against the Communists during the McCarthy era. Job Matusow, who turned again and said he'd lied and made it up, and that the Justice Department knew he was lying and, in fact, encouraged it. Job Matusow, the most hated man in America. Job Matusow, Cockyboo the clown. Job Matusow, who's been married 10 times to nine different women and is still one of the loneliest old men you'd ever want to meet. Job Matusow, manager, program director, and creator of SCAT-TV, the first and only public access station in central Utah. Job Matusow, con man who tells you upfront that he's a con man and then cons you. Job Matusow, coyote of all coyotes.
约伯·马图索，生于布朗克斯的犹太人。约伯·马图索，准备死在犹他州格伦伍德的摩门教徒。约伯·马图索，欧洲解放者。约伯·马图索，共产党员。约伯·马图索，转而成为麦卡锡时代反共的付费告密者。约伯·马图索，再次反戈，说自己撒了谎、捏造了事实，司法部知道他在撒谎，甚至还鼓励他这样做。约伯·马图索，美国最受憎恨的人。约伯·马图索，小丑Cockyboo。约伯·马图索，结过10次婚，娶过9个不同女人，至今仍是你所能遇见的最孤独的老人之一。约伯·马图索，犹他州中部第一个也是唯一一个公共接入频道SCAT-TV的经理、项目总监和创办人。约伯·马图索，一个坦白自己是骗子然后继续骗你的骗子。约伯·马图索，狡诈之徒中的狡诈之徒。
I represented the most anarchistic of anarchists. I turned on the Communists and then I turned on the extreme right, and put a plague on both their houses.
我代理过最无政府主义的无政府主义者。我背叛了共产党，然后又背叛了极右翼，诅咒了他们两家。
The trick with a coyote is to not take sides. The trick is to see all things as being equal. This means accepting whatever the coyote says as being true, but it also means you accept the exact opposite of whatever the coyote says as being true as well.
“狡诈之徒”（Coyote）的诀窍就是不选边站。诀窍是把万事万物看作平等的。这意味着接受狡诈之徒所说的一切都是真的，但也意味着你同时也接受与他所说的完全相反的一切也是真的。
Yeah, we have a song in our Magic Mouse Children's Theatre, which goes like, [SINGING] when I spend the whole day cooking and it burns when I'm not looking, I just smile and shrug my shoulders, that's the way it is. That's the way it is, by golly. That's the way it is, by golly. That's the way it is, by golly. That's the way it is. [END SINGING]. And that's the way it is.
是的，我们在“魔术老鼠儿童剧院”有一首歌，歌词是这样的，[唱歌]当我花了一整天做饭，我不注意的时候它却糊了，我只是微笑耸耸肩，事情就是这样。事情就是这样，天哪。事情就是这样，天哪。事情就是这样，天哪。事情就是这样。[歌声结束]。这就是事情的样子。
This is the way Job tells the story. This is the way he explains the events that led up to the worst day of his life and his decision to call himself Job, like from the Bible. First he was a kid on the streets in the Bronx, running bets for Phil the bookie, and delivering bribes to policemen. Then his brother went off to the Second World War and got shot down over Germany. Then Job enlisted, and managed through a miracle to find his brother's unmarked grave in Nuremberg. Then he helped liberate Europe by digging bodies from out of the rubble and hanging out in coffee shops with French intellectuals.
这就是约伯讲述故事的方式。这就是他解释导致他一生中最糟糕日子、以及他决定像《圣经》中那样自称约伯的原因的方式。起初，他是在布朗克斯街头混的孩子，为赌球经纪人菲尔跑腿，给警察送贿赂。后来他的哥哥去参加二战，在德国上空被击落。接着约伯参军，奇迹般地在纽伦堡找到了哥哥的无名墓。随后，他通过从废墟中挖掘尸体，并与法国知识分子在咖啡馆闲逛，协助解放了欧洲。
When I joined the Communist Party, it was as a result of the experiences with Communists in Europe in World War II. I found the Communists were the only substantial group of people who effectively stood up to Hitler and fought him effectively in occupied Europe. And wherever I went and liberated Europe, and I was part of the infantry that liberated Europe, I found Communists who were romantic to me, who were real. In the Ernest Hemingway sense, the romance of Communism. And you hear songs like, [SINGING "VIVA LA QUINTA BRIGADE"]. Viva the 15th brigade. They stood up to Franco. [SINGING "VIVA LA QUINTA BRIGADE"].
当我加入共产党时，这是我在二战期间与欧洲共产党人接触的结果。我发现共产党是唯一真正站出来反抗希特勒，并在被占领的欧洲有效地与他战斗的实质性群体。无论我走到哪里，无论在哪里解放欧洲——我是解放欧洲的步兵部队的一员——我都发现了那些对我来说浪漫、真实的人。用海明威的话说，共产主义的浪漫。你会听到这样的歌，[唱《Viva La Quinta Brigada》]。万岁，第15旅。他们反抗了佛朗哥。[唱《Viva La Quinta Brigada》]。
So it wasn't difficult for me to become a Communist.
所以，对我来说成为一名共产党员并不难。
Job joined the party in New York City in 1946. By 1947, he was a full-time employee, operating the switchboard and screening calls at the national headquarters during the day, and organizing youth meetings at night. He says he had the honor to raise the first ever Chinese Communist flag flown in the United States. He says he carried Paul Robeson, Jr., under a blanket in the back seat of his car into the riots of Peekskill. He was, he says, deeply involved in these struggles.
约伯于1946年在纽约市加入该党。到1947年，他成为了一名全职员工，白天在全国总部操作交换机并筛选电话，晚上组织青年会议。他说他有幸升起了在美国境内升起的第一面中国共产党旗帜。他说他曾把小保罗·罗伯逊裹在毯子里藏在车后座，带进了皮克斯基尔骚乱中。他说他深度参与了这些斗争。
In the late '40s, it was a radical thing to be a Communist. It was the beginning of the Cold War, the beginning of the Evil Empire. Lots of people, in fact most people, believed that a war with the Soviet Union was inevitable. Then, in 1950, we did go to war with Communists in Korea. And at that point, it was not radical to be a Communist, it was impossible to be a Communist. Being a Communist meant losing your job and being publicly vilified, maybe even going to jail.
在40年代后期，做一名共产党员是一件激进的事。那是冷战的开始，是“邪恶帝国”的开始。许多人，实际上大多数人，认为与苏联的战争是不可避免的。然后，在1950年，我们确实在朝鲜与共产党人开战了。在那一点上，做一名共产党员不再是激进的，而是不可能的。成为一名共产党员意味着丢掉工作、受到公众抨击，甚至可能坐牢。
Job, being more coyote than Communist, saw that things were getting kind of hot. He says when things get hot, he finds another place to play, at least that's how he tells the story sometimes. Other times, he tells it like this.
约伯比共产党员更像个“狡诈之徒”，他看出情况开始变得火热。他说，当情况变得火热时，他会找别的地方玩，至少他有时是这样讲述这个故事的。而另一些时候，他会这样说。
The Communist Party to me became very phony, phony as a $3 bill. I found it hypocritical and dishonest, and maybe because I was too romantic when I entered into it. And I figured the Cold War was getting crazier, the prosecutions, the persecutions were getting crazier, so I called the FBI. I dialed [UNINTELLIGIBLE] 23500. And I said, hi, my name is Harvey Matusow, I'm a member of the Communist Party, I want to talk to you. And that was the extent of the conversation, and we made a time to meet.
对我来说，共产党变得非常虚伪，像三美元钞票一样虚伪。我发现它伪善且不诚实，也许是因为我加入时太浪漫了。我想冷战变得越来越疯狂，起诉和迫害也越来越疯狂，所以我打了FBI的电话。我拨了[无法辨认] 23500。我说，嘿，我叫哈维·马图索，我是共产党员，我想和你们谈谈。谈话内容仅限于此，我们约定了见面时间。
So the government wanted me to be a witness. And I met at a rendezvous point on the East River Drive, real clandestine. And this limousine pulls up. This guy gets out, introduces himself as Roy Cohn. I get in the back of the limo, and we take off. And we talk in the car.
政府想让我做证人。我们在东河大道的会合点见了面，非常隐秘。一辆豪华轿车开了过来。那个人下来，自我介绍说是罗伊·科恩。我钻进轿车后座，我们出发了。我们在车里交谈。
And he's interviewing me. And this is a guy who grew up in my neighborhood in the Bronx. We have a lot in common. We're the same age. We were born a few months apart. And we hit it off real well. And while we were getting ready to prepare me for my testimony in the case, I used to go out and party with Roy Cohn.
他在采访我。这家伙和我一样在布朗克斯的同一个街区长大。我们有很多共同点。我们年龄相同。我们出生时间只差几个月。我们相处得非常好。在他们准备让我为案件作证时，我经常和罗伊·科恩出去聚会。
What would you do when you partied?
你们聚会时会做什么？
We'd go to the Stork Club. We'd go to 21. We'd party. You know, how the young guys in their mid-20s go out and party.
我们会去鹳鸟俱乐部。我们会去“21”餐厅。我们会狂欢。你知道，就像二十几岁的年轻人出去狂欢那样。
Job became a paid political informer, which was also a radical thing to be. At that time in the early '50s, the exploits of FBI informers were celebrated in motion pictures, in television serials, in books, and in magazine articles. They were portrayed as brave heroes who risked their lives as Communists, only to emerge as true patriots, indispensable, as J. Edgar Hoover once said, to the American way of life. And it was a lucrative profession. The most charismatic informers supplemented their incomes with generous lecture fees, royalties from bestselling books, as well as radio, television, and film rights to their harrowing exposes of the red menace.
约伯成了一名付费政治告密者，这也是一件激进的事情。在50年代初，FBI告密者的事迹在电影、电视连续剧、书籍和杂志文章中备受赞誉。他们被描绘成勇敢的英雄，冒着生命危险混入共产党内部，最终成为真正的爱国者——正如J·埃德加·胡佛曾经说过的，他们对美国生活方式是不可或缺的。这曾是一项有利可图的职业。最有魅力的告密者通过丰厚的演讲费、畅销书版税，以及将他们关于“红色威胁”的惊人揭露改编成广播、电视和电影作品的权利，来增加收入。
Though only 26 years old, Job met with immediate success. In his first appearance on the witness stand in 1951, at a hearing of the House Committee on Un-American Activities, he was billed as an authority on the Communist conspiracy to penetrate the youth of America. Overnight, his name was in the headlines. "Witness Bears Plot to Infiltrate the Boy Scouts." "Secret FBI Man Reveals 3,500 Students Recruited Here for Red Fifth Column." "Communists Use Sex to Lure Members." Job was a hit, a rising star.
尽管只有26岁，约伯还是立即获得了成功。1951年，他在众议院非美活动调查委员会的听证会上首次出庭，被宣传为揭露共产党渗透美国青年的权威。一夜之间，他的名字上了头条。“目击者证实渗透童子军的阴谋。”“FBI秘密特工揭露3500名学生被招募为红色第五纵队。”“共产党利用性诱惑成员。”约伯是个轰动人物，一颗冉冉升起的新星。
I play-acted. I made up a game. I made up a story. I did something nobody else did. All these other witnesses were old men and old women. And here I come on, a war veteran from two wars that he enlisted in in his 20s, and is talking about Communism and youth. And all these other guys were in the 50s and 60s. I was a breath of fresh air for them.
我是在演戏。我编了一场游戏。我编了一个故事。我做了没人做过的事。所有其他的证人都是些老人和老太婆。而我，一个二十几岁就参加过两场战争的退伍军人，站出来谈论共产主义和青年。而其他人都五六十岁了。对他们来说，我是新鲜空气。
Job testified in front of the House Committee on Un-American Activities, the Senate Internal Security Subcommittee, the Government Operations Committee, the Subversive Activities Control Board hearings, and in two criminal prosecutions for the Justice Department, one of which was the famous First Amendment case against union organizer, Clinton Jencks. Job named hundreds of people as Communists or Communist sympathizers, many of whom had been his friends.
约伯在众议院非美活动调查委员会、参议院内部安全小组委员会、政府运作委员会、颠覆活动控制委员会的听证会上，以及为司法部进行的两次刑事起诉中作证，其中之一就是著名的针对工会组织者克林顿·詹克斯的第一修正案案件。约伯指名道姓地称数百人为共产党员或共产主义同情者，其中许多人曾经是他的朋友。
When he ran out of people to name, he started making up stories, anything that would make a good performance, anything that would make it in the papers. For instance, on one of his lecture tours, he told a group of high school students in Pocatello, Idaho that he'd been sent by a Czechoslovakian delegation to New Mexico, where he set up a system of espionage at Los Alamos. He also said that the Soviet Union has scheduled 1961 as the year it would take over the United States. The press loved him, and he loved the press.
当他指不出人名时，他开始编造故事，任何能让他出彩、任何能上报纸的故事。例如，在一次演讲巡回中，他告诉爱达荷州波卡特洛的一群高中生，他曾被捷克斯洛伐克代表团派往新墨西哥州，在那里建立了一个洛斯阿拉莫斯的间谍系统。他还说苏联已将1961年定为接管美国的一年。媒体爱他，他也爱媒体。
Here I was meeting with people, editors of the Hearst newspapers, making up stories with them. I mean, I was going out and having dinner every night with the columnist Walter Winchell, and he fell in love with me. So I'd go out at his old Cadillac convertible, and he had a police radio-- and he was the best known journalist in the country at the time-- and we'd go chase police calls. He'd listen to the police calls and he'd show up, and he wore a gun. The guy was a madman, and I'd hang out with him.
当时我经常和赫斯特报系的编辑们见面，和他们一起编造故事。我是说，我每晚都和专栏作家沃尔特·温切尔一起吃饭，他爱上了我。我坐他的旧凯迪拉克敞篷车，他车上有警用无线电——他是当时全国最知名的记者——我们一起去追赶警方通报。他听着无线电，然后赶到现场，他还带着枪。那家伙是个疯子，我就和他混在一起。
And I'd hang out every night. I'd go to Toot Shor's bar and hang out with all the celebrities from Hollywood and big shot, big [BLEEP], you know. It was a whole different dance, a whole different ballgame. Where I fabricated stories is like, I said-- because I belonged to the American Newspaper Guild and was involved in organizing the union-- that the Sunday New York Times I said had 126 Communists working for it, when they only had either 78 or 96 employees. At this point, I forget which figure. And nobody, not even the New York Times , ever questioned that.
我每晚都和他混。我会去Toot Shor的酒吧，和所有好莱坞的大人物、大[哔——]混在一起，你知道。那是完全不同的舞会，完全不同的比赛。至于我编造的故事，比如我说——因为我加入了美国报业协会并参与了工会组织——我说周日《纽约时报》有126名共产党员工作，而他们当时只有78或96名员工。此时，我忘了具体数字。没有人，甚至《纽约时报》自己，都从未质疑过这一点。
Did you know that it was going to be on the news that night?
你知道那天晚上它会上新闻吗？
Oh, yeah, every night for weeks. And I'd turn on the box and we'd watch the news, and there I was, day after day, freaking out Americans.
哦，是的，连续几周，每晚都会。我会打开电视，我们看着新闻，一天又一天，我出现在屏幕上，吓坏了美国人。
And you knew you were doing it?
你知道你在做什么吗？
Oh, I was very conscious of it, yeah. I knew I had the whole nation. I was in everybody's living room. It's a very strong feeling.
哦，我非常有意识，是的。我知道我掌握了整个国家。我在每个人的客厅里。这是一种非常强烈的感受。
In 1952, after Job was already a hotshot paid political informer, he walked into Senator Joseph McCarthy's office in Washington and offered his services in McCarthy's reelection campaign. He became, he says, close friends with McCarthy. He says he even delivered 70% of McCarthy's campaign speeches when the senator was in the hospital for alcohol-related illnesses. Through McCarthy, Job met the heiress, Arvilla Bentley, one of McCarthy's biggest financial supporters. She became Job's second wife.
1952年，在约伯已经是一名炙手可热的付费政治告密者后，他走进华盛顿参议员约瑟夫·麦卡锡的办公室，主动提出在麦卡锡的连任竞选中提供服务。他说他成了麦卡锡的密友。他说，当参议员因酗酒相关疾病住院时，他甚至代劳了麦卡锡70%的竞选演讲。通过麦卡锡，约伯认识了女继承人阿维拉·本特利，她是麦卡锡最大的财政支持者之一。她成了约伯的第二任妻子。
It was unreal, married a woman who had millions of dollars and she was a party giver and lived on fancy Foxhall Road. The house is now the German ambassador's residence. And here I came from the streets of the Bronx running bets for Phil the bookie, and I'm throwing dinner parties in Washington.
那太不真实了，娶了一个拥有数百万美元的女人，她举办派对，住在奢华的福克斯霍尔路上。那座房子现在是德国大使官邸。我本是从布朗克斯街头为赌球经纪人菲尔跑腿的，现在却在华盛顿举办晚宴。
My next door neighbor is Governor Averell Harriman, or ambassador Harriman at that time. And when he moved out to go back to New York to become governor, Secretary of Treasury Humphrey moved in next door. He'd be working the garden, and I'd be out talking to the secretary of treasury because he was my neighbor. It wasn't a real world. It was so surreal, it was like a Salvador Dali painting. The only thing it missed were the melting clocks rolling off the rocks and the furniture.
我的隔壁邻居是艾夫里尔·哈里曼州长，或者当时的大使哈里曼。当他搬回纽约去做州长时，财政部长汉弗莱搬到了隔壁。他会在花园里工作，我会在外面和财政部长聊天，因为他是我的邻居。那不是真实世界。太超现实了，就像萨尔瓦多·达利的画。唯一缺的就是从岩石和家具上滚落的融化的钟表。
We're in Job's car, driving down the highway in central Utah. His car's a 1970 Cadillac Brougham DeVille, of a color I've studied but am unable to discern, tarnished gold or tarnished silver, or both. He got the car, he says, by getting down on his knees and praying. He asked God to give him a car, and God gave him this one.
我们坐在约伯的车里，在犹他州中部的公路上行驶。他的车是1970年的凯迪拉克Brougham DeVille，颜色我研究过但无法辨认，是锈金色还是锈银色，或者两者皆有。他说这辆车是他跪下来祈祷得到的。他祈求上帝赐予他一辆车，上帝就给了他这一辆。
I've lived in London, in Paris, in New York, Melbourne, and Sydney, in Berlin, in San Francisco, in Boston, and you name it and I've lived there. But none of it beats what I got here.
我住过伦敦、巴黎、纽约、墨尔本、悉尼、柏林、旧金山、波士顿，你想得到的城市我都住过。但没有任何地方比得上我现在拥有的。
Two years ago, Job came to the small farming community of Glenwood, Utah, in an old school bus loaded with consumer-grade video production equipment. And in short order, he started Six Counties Access Television, a public access station that shows high school band practice, the local church choir doing "The Messiah," drill team competitions, and also the Magic Mouse Magazine, Job's nonviolent kid show.
两年前，约伯坐着一辆装满消费级视频制作设备的老校车，来到了犹他州格伦伍德这个小农业社区。没过多久，他就创办了“六县接入电视”，一个公共接入频道，播放高中乐队练习、“弥赛亚”当地教堂合唱团演出、钻探队比赛，还有约伯的非暴力儿童节目《魔术老鼠杂志》。
He has more than 100 hours of Magic Mouse Magazine on tape. Each show is hosted by Job playing Cockyboo the clown. Right now, we're in the car, driving around, changing the Magic Mouse tapes at various cable downlink stations scattered around the countryside. On the seat between us are two little dogs, tiny dogs, each so small I can close my thumb and index finger around their necks. And one dog is on top and humping the other dog, and she's looking up at me with big, woeful eyes, all the woe of [UNINTELLIGIBLE] conception.
他有超过100小时的《魔术老鼠杂志》录像带。每个节目都由扮演小丑Cockyboo的约伯主持。现在，我们正在车里到处跑，在散布在乡村各处的不同电缆下行站更换《魔术老鼠》的录像带。我们中间的座位上有两只小狗，非常小，小到我可以单手捏住它们的脖子。其中一只狗在另一只上面抽动，它用那双忧郁的大眼睛看着我，带着所有受造物的哀愁。
Job is driving the car, but he has some back trouble and he can't really sit up high enough to see over the dashboard or the long hood of the car. And then he has the car in cruise control, so his feet are way back from the pedals, nowhere near the pedals, and it's like he's just acting like he's driving, like the car is floating down the road on a cloud. Job tells me he was responsible for the creation of the Freedom of Information Act. He tells me he was the person who started the myth about getting high off smoking banana peels. He tells me he was the developer of the stringless Yo-Yo, which, he says, in 1957, was the second-best selling children's toy in America, right behind the hula hoop.
约伯在开车，但他腰不好，无法坐得足够高来看到仪表盘或汽车长长的引擎盖。而且他开了定速巡航，所以他的脚离踏板很远，根本碰不到踏板，感觉就像他在假装开车，就像汽车在云端飘行。约伯告诉我，他是《信息自由法案》的创作者。他告诉我，关于吸食香蕉皮能产生快感的谣言是他传出来的。他告诉我，他是无绳悠悠球的开发者，他说在1957年，这曾是美国第二畅销的儿童玩具，仅次于呼啦圈。
He tells me that there's more creative talent in these small Utah towns than anywhere else he's been in the world.
他告诉我，这些犹他州小镇所拥有的创造才能比他去过的世界上任何地方都多。
There's more creative talent in this valley, per capita, than any place I have ever been on the planet Earth, anywhere. And it's got an innocence about it, which makes it beautiful for me. It's not jaundiced, as Hollywood and New York is jaundiced.
这个山谷里的人均创造才能比我到过的地球上任何地方都要多。而且它带有一种纯真，这对我来说很美。它不像好莱坞和纽约那样有着偏见。
We stop by a mailbox in front of a small white house. The mailbox says "Mike," just Mike. Mike comes out of the house and gets in the backseat, wearing a balaclava ski mask pulled down over his face, like we're going to rob a bank or something. We stay in the car for about an hour, and Mike doesn't take the mask off. Mike is the television station's technical engineer, and Job's best friend. He's also the opposite of Job in every way.
我们在一个小房子前的邮箱旁停下。邮箱上写着“Mike”，就叫麦克。麦克从屋里出来坐进后座，脸上拉着一个巴拉克拉法帽，像我们要去抢银行似的。我们在车里待了一个小时，麦克没有摘下帽子。麦克是电视台的技术工程师，也是约伯最好的朋友。他在各方面都和约伯相反。
Job likes to talk, and he likes to talk about himself and how he fits into the bigger picture of things. Mike almost never talks, and when he does, he talks about flywheels and edit functions and videocassette recorders. Job likes to be seen and known. Mike hides behind his balaclava. Job has dogs, but he's actually much more like a cat himself. Mike has a cat, but he's actually much more like a dog himself. And so on.
约伯喜欢说话，喜欢谈论自己以及他如何融入更大的格局。麦克几乎从不说话，即使开口，也只谈论飞轮、编辑功能和录像机。约伯喜欢被看见和被认识。麦克藏在他的巴拉克拉法帽后面。约伯养狗，但他自己其实更像猫。麦克养猫，但他自己其实更像狗。诸如此类。
The best way I can describe Mike to somebody is that he couldn't tell a lie if he wanted to. And I don't meet many people of that pure a spirit much in my life, very rare. And when I meet somebody with that pure a spirit, I want to nurture it and enjoy it and be around it, because it'll never sell you short. It'll never be dishonest with you.
描述麦克最好的方式是，他就算想说谎也说不出来。我一生中没见过多少如此纯粹灵魂的人，非常罕见。当我遇到这样纯粹灵魂的人时，我想要培育它、享受它、陪伴它，因为它永远不会让你失望。它永远不会对你不诚实。
So at one time, you were associating and hanging out with some of the most important people of the century. And now you live in Glenwood, Utah, and you hang out with Mike.
所以曾经有段时间，你和本世纪最重要的一些人交往。而现在你住在犹他州格伦伍德，和麦克混在一起。
Hang out with my friend, Mike. And he's very special.
和我的朋友麦克混在一起。他非常特别。
By 1954, the whole witch hunt of Communists was beginning to fall apart. Edward R. Murrow broadcast his famous expose on Joe McCarthy, and then McCarthy himself was investigated in the Army-McCarthy hearings. McCarthy responded in part by turning up the heat on Job, asking him to supply names of writers and journalists who were Commies or sympathizers. But by this time, Job was having second thoughts. Being a paid informer had been like being a Communist, in that it had been fun for a while, but then it got scary. He decided it was maybe time to come clean.
到1954年，整个针对共产党员的猎巫行动开始瓦解。爱德华·R·莫罗播出了关于乔·麦卡锡的著名揭露，随后麦卡锡本人也受到了陆军-麦卡锡听证会的调查。麦卡锡的回应部分是向约伯施压，要求他提供共党分子或同情者的作家和记者名单。但这时，约伯已经有了其他的想法。做付费告密者曾像做共产党员一样，有一阵子很有趣，但后来变得令人恐惧。他觉得也许是时候坦白了。
This is when job recognized Jesus Christ as his personal saviour, and was baptized into the Mormon church.
这时约伯承认耶稣基督是他的个人救主，并受洗加入了摩门教。
I took to it like a duck to water. Are you kidding? The Mormon church? Wow. Everything I wanted in my life in this gospel, in this lifestyle, and in the way the people were, in the caring for each other. And then my conscience really got to bum me out. Here I was baptized in the name of Jesus Christ, and I was living with all these misdeeds. And I finally said I gotta stop the bull [BLEEP], and it's not blacklisting was my business. But I was a false witness upfront, all the way. Let it go.
我像鸭子戏水一样适应了。开玩笑吗？摩门教？哇。我在这个福音、这种生活方式以及人们相处的方式中找到了我生命中想要的一切，那种彼此关怀。然后我的良心真的开始让我难受了。我受洗归入耶稣基督的名下，却带着所有这些恶行生活。我终于说，我必须停止这些扯淡，并不是黑名单是我的生意。我是彻头彻尾的伪证者。让它过去吧。
According to a friend of mine who is a wise man, and also a good Mormon, there are three things you need to do in order to repent, in order to achieve forgiveness. The first is, you have to try not to do the bad thing again. The second is, you have to try to compensate your victims. The third is, you have to find some kind of peace with yourself. Of these three, the third is by far the most difficult to achieve.
据我的一位智者朋友说，他也是个好摩门教徒，悔改以获得宽恕需要做三件事。第一，你必须努力不再做坏事。第二，你必须努力补偿受害者。第三，你必须与自己达成某种和解。在这三点中，第三点是最难达成的。
Job started with the first two things by visiting and apologizing to some of the people he'd named in front of the committees, people whose lives he'd ruined. He told them that he wanted to try to pay them back by writing a book about how he lied and made things up, a book that would hopefully bring down the McCarthy era once and for all. Then he asked each of them if they might want to put up some money to help get the book published.
约伯从前两件事开始，他去拜访并向他在委员会面前指名道姓的一些人道歉，这些人原本的生活被他毁了。他告诉他们，他想通过写一本书来弥补，讲述他是如何撒谎和编造事实的，这本书希望能一劳永逸地结束麦卡锡时代。然后他问他们中是否有人愿意出资帮助出版这本书。
It felt real good to go to people and ask forgiveness.
去向人们请求宽恕的感觉真的很棒。
Were any of them upset?
他们中有人生气吗？
When I go to somebody and say, hey look, I was an asshole, I was this, I was that, and I'm sorry, and I shouldn't have done it, and please forgive me, and if you don't, I'm still asking your forgiveness, and that's a good clean feeling. It's a rich feeling. It balances the body out, man. It really does.
当我走到某人面前说，嘿，听着，我曾是个混蛋，我做了这个做了那个，我很抱歉，我不应该那样做，请原谅我，如果你不原谅，我也依然请求你的宽恕，那是一种很好、很干净的感觉。那是一种丰盈的感受。它能让身体达到平衡，伙计。真的。
None of the men that Job visited wanted to publish his book, however. And he decided that it was time to leave his old life behind, and go to Utah and marry a Mormon girl. He set off by walking and hitchhiking across Texas, wearing German desert army fatigues, black boots, a black beret, a black beard, and a backpack full of Old Testament puppets. At night, he'd stop in hospitals and small towns and ask if he could perform his puppet show for the kids in exchange for a bed and something to eat.
然而，没有一个被约伯拜访过的人愿意出版他的书。他决定是时候抛弃旧生活，去犹他州娶个摩门教女孩了。他出发了，穿着德国沙漠军装、黑靴子、贝雷帽、留着黑胡子，背着装满旧约木偶的背包，步行并搭便车穿过得克萨斯州。晚上，他会停在医院和小镇，询问是否可以用木偶戏换取床位和食物。
He traveled like this across Texas and into New Mexico. And in New Mexico, he got a message from his mother. A publisher in New York wanted him to write his book. Even though Job was very close to a nice, quiet life in Utah, he decided he had an obligation to set the record straight. So he went back to New York City.
他这样穿越得克萨斯进入新墨西哥州。在新墨西哥州，他收到了母亲的消息。纽约的一家出版商想让他写那本书。尽管约伯离犹他州那种平静的好生活只有一步之遥，但他觉得有义务澄清事实。于是他回到了纽约市。
Coming up, trying to set the record straight, and because of it, ending up in prison the most hated man in America. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，试图澄清事实，却因此以美国最受憎恨之人的身份进了监狱。稍后继续，来自国际公共广播电台，节目将继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, people whose lives were pinned in history, caught up in huge historical events, and what they made of their actions years after the fact, when it was quiet enough to make sense of anything. Scott Carrier's story about Harvey Matusow, Job Matusow, continues. Job has moved back to New York, invited to write a book, hoping to set the record straight.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带给您各种不同的故事。今天的节目讲述的是那些被钉在历史中的人，他们被卷入巨大的历史事件中，以及在多年后、当一切平静到足以理清头绪时，他们对自己行为的看法。斯科特·卡里尔关于哈维·马图索——也就是约伯·马图索——的故事继续。约伯搬回了纽约，受邀写一本书，希望能澄清事实。
The publishers set him up with an apartment in Manhattan, and a stenographer. And in four months, Job dictated False Witness , his book describing in detail how he'd lied and fabricated stories, and how the government prosecutors had known he was lying and even participated in the process. In particular, he named Roy Cohn, his old friend and government prosecutor in the trial of the communist leaders in New York, and also in the Jencks trial.
出版商为他安排了曼哈顿的一间公寓和一名速记员。四个月内，约伯口述完成了《伪证者》，书中详细描述了他如何撒谎和编造故事，以及政府检察官是如何知道他在撒谎并参与其中的。他特别点名了罗伊·科恩，他曾经的朋友和纽约共产党领导人审判中的政府检察官，也是在詹克斯案中的检察官。
In his book, and also under oath, in an affidavit, Job said that Cohn had known that he was lying in the trials, and had even encouraged him to do it. Cohn denied everything. Even before the book was published, Job was called in front of some of the same committees he'd appeared before as an expert witness, only now he was the accused.
在书中，以及在宣誓证词中，约伯说科恩知道他在审判中撒谎，甚至鼓励他这样做。科恩否认了一切。甚至在书出版之前，约伯就被传唤到他曾作为专家证人出庭的一些委员会面前，只是现在他成了被告。
am not an expert on this subject of Communism. I was not a leader in the Communist Party. I was a Communist flunky in a club on the lower east side of New York. And through a few lies, I built myself up into an expert on Communism. And you expect me to start sounding off about what the Communist Party thinks and does, about what orders come from Moscow, if any?
我不是共产主义这一学科的专家。我不是共产党里的领导人。我只是纽约下东区一个俱乐部里的共党小卒。通过几个谎言，我把自己包装成了共产主义专家。你们难道期待我开始高谈阔论共产党在想什么、做什么，以及来自莫斯科的命令是什么，如果有的话？
I was finally letting it out and kicking all the shackles off this play-acting. I wasn't play-acting when I was testifying. I knew they were going to put me in jail, so what could they do?
我终于要把这一切释放出来，踢开这所有演戏的枷锁了。我在作证时并没有在演戏。我知道他们会把我关进监狱，那他们还能怎么样？
Are you afraid of the truth, sir?
你害怕真相吗，先生？
Sir?
先生？
Are you afraid of the truth, sir?
你害怕真相吗，先生？
I am not afraid of any truth that you can give, because I don't think there's any truth in your body.
我不害怕你们能给出的任何真相，因为我觉得你们身体里根本没有任何真相。
They were freaking out. Like Sourwine, the chief council of the committee, says, haven't you called yourself leader of the Communist youth movement? And I responded, I lied. And everybody laughed.
他们当时吓坏了。就像委员会的首席法律顾问索尔怀恩说，你不是自称是共产主义青年运动的领袖吗？我回答说，我撒谎了。大家都笑了。
Haven't you found yourself leader of the Communist youth movement in this country?
你不是发现自己是这个国家共产主义青年运动的领袖吗？
I lied.
我撒谎了。
You're the one who's responsible for my role as a witness, not I. You're responsible by creating the fear and hysteria in this country, where people can't talk to one another, where neighbor can't talk to neighbor without fear of being called a Communist. You're responsible for the hysteria.
你是对我作为证人的角色负责的人，不是我。你通过在这个国家制造恐惧和歇斯底里来负责，人们无法相互交谈，邻居无法与邻居交谈，因为害怕被叫成共产党员。你要对这种歇斯底里负责。
We forced you?
是我们强迫你的？
Yes, sir, by creating a fear and hysteria in this country which this country's never seen before, where people can't turn around and talk to their neighbors without fear of being called a Communist. Honest, decent people. You're the one who's responsible for my role as a witness, not I.
是的，先生，通过在这个国家制造了前所未有的恐惧和歇斯底里，人们连转个身和邻居说话都要害怕被扣上共产党的帽子。诚实、体面的人。你是对我作为证人的角色负责的人，不是我。
I knew that when I wrote the book, I was going to go to jail. There was no question in my mind.
写那本书的时候我就知道，我会进监狱。我心里毫无疑问。
From the beginning, when you were writing the book?
从一开始，写书的时候？
Oh yeah. When that became part of my consciousness, I knew, as sure as God made little apples, I was either going to be assassinated or go to jail, or both. And I was perfectly prepared for it. In fact, part of me wanted to be assassinated. It would've been a great release, finally. I wrote the book, I did the recantation, I straightened the record out, and if somebody wants to blow me away and let me go home to God, I'll be home with my father. What a blessing.
哦，是的。当它成为我意识的一部分时，我就像上帝创造万物一样确定，我要么会被暗杀，要么会坐牢，或者两者皆有。我对此做好了充分准备。事实上，我内心的一部分希望被暗杀。那将是一种巨大的解脱，终于结束了。我写了书，我做了撤回声明，我澄清了记录，如果有人想把我干掉让我回家见上帝，我就会回到我父亲身边。多么大的福气。
This brings us up to the worst day of Job's life, the day he decided to call himself Job, like from the Bible, only if you'll remember, the Job in the Bible was an innocent man, a virtuous man, who suffered only because of a bet God made with the Devil, whereas Job from Glenwood, Utah is a man who, through his own selfish desires, brought pain and suffering to a lot of people.
这把我们带到了约伯一生中最糟糕的一天，他决定像《圣经》中那样自称约伯的那一天。如果你们还记得，圣经里的约伯是一个无辜的人，一个品德高尚的人，他受苦仅仅是因为上帝和魔鬼打了个赌；而来自犹他州格伦伍德的约伯是一个人，因为他自己的自私欲望，给许多人带来了痛苦和折磨。
In his book False Witness , published in 1955, Job confesses his sins and writes about how he was a bad man who's trying to repent. But when he tells the same story now, in 1998, he sometimes describes the events as if he were a victim of circumstance, or at least that things were never black and white, and that he was simply doing the best he could all along.
在1955年出版的《伪证者》中，约伯忏悔了自己的罪孽，写到他是一个试图悔改的坏人。但现在，1998年，当他讲述同一个故事时，他有时会将这些事件描述为他是环境的受害者，或者至少事情从来不是黑白分明的，他自始至终只是尽力而为。
80% of the people who I named before the committee were Communists, and they were sure of it. There wasn't a question of my lying about it. What was wrong was that I was naming them at all. But at the same time, I started to have a fantasy, and based on the experiences I had in Europe at the end of World War II.
我在委员会面前点名的人中，80%是共产党员，他们对此心知肚明。我撒谎的问题根本不存在。错误在于我竟然指出了他们。但同时，我开始产生一种幻想，基于我在二战结束时在欧洲的经历。
There were many French Communists who would tell me stories of how they, repugnant as it was, went to work for the SS and the Gestapo and the German authorities that occupied France. And they did so so they could spy on the Germans. And I used to fantasize-- and it was strictly a fantasy, and I don't want to give it any more credence than that-- that I went to the FBI and did to the FBI what these people had done to the Gestapo.
许多法国共产党人曾告诉我，他们——尽管这令人反感——是如何去为党卫军、盖世太保和占领法国的德国当局工作的。他们这样做是为了刺探德国人。我过去常常幻想——这纯粹是幻想，我不想给它任何可信度——我去了FBI，并对FBI做了这些人对盖世太保做的事。
In the end, Job was sent to jail for perjury. When he got out after four years in 1961, he found work publishing avant-garde art books and helping to edit the East Village Other, which, according to Job, was the first underground newspaper in America. In the '60s and early '70s, he traveled to England, France, and Australia. But everywhere he went, his past was right behind him.
最终，约伯因伪证罪被送进监狱。1961年出狱后，他从事先锋艺术书籍出版，并协助编辑了《东村其他报》，据约伯说，这是美国第一份地下报纸。60年代和70年代初，他游历了英国、法国和澳大利亚。但无论走到哪里，他的过去都紧跟在身后。
So I realized at that point that, regardless of what I did, whatever accomplishment I may have, it's going to be attacked and its foundations are going to be chipped away at by the past and people's view and their perception of me in the McCarthy period. And at that point, I realized that I really am not going to care about what they think anymore.
所以我意识到，无论我做什么，无论我取得什么成就，它都会受到攻击，它的基础会被过去、会被人们在麦卡锡时期对我的观点和认知所蚕食。在那一点上，我意识到我真的不再关心他们怎么想了。
Job came back to the States in 1973 and began to commit his life to serving others and doing the Lord's work, as a sort of penance. He set up homeless shelters and soup kitchens in New York and Massachusetts, and collected used clothes and food that he drove out to South Dakota and delivered to the Sioux Indians. He moved around a lot, from one city to another, from one wife to another.
约伯1973年回到美国，开始致力于为他人服务，做主的工，作为一种赎罪。他在纽约和马萨诸塞州建立了收容所和流动厨房，收集旧衣服和食物，开车送到南达科他州分发给苏族印第安人。他频繁搬迁，从一个城市到另一个城市，从一个妻子到另一个妻子。
He was like Chuck Connors in the TV show, The Rifleman, an officer in the US Calvary who had somehow blacked out in battle and deserted his men, and was court martialed. They broke the rifleman's saber, and he was branded, scorned as the man who ran. Every week, the rifleman tried to redeem himself by saving lives and helping people out of trouble, and by getting rid of the bad guys in town. But he could never shake his past. He could never even remember what had happened.
他就像电视剧《神枪手》里的查克·康纳斯，美国骑兵队的一名军官，在战斗中不知怎么昏迷了并抛弃了他的部下，上了军事法庭。他们折断了神枪手的军刀，他被打上了烙印，作为逃兵被唾弃。每周，神枪手都试图通过拯救生命和帮助人们解决麻烦、赶走镇上的坏人来救赎自己。但他永远无法摆脱他的过去。他甚至永远无法想起当时究竟发生了什么。
In 1977, Job moved to Tucson, Arizona, where he fell in with a troupe of street musicians and performers that he managed and organized into the Magic Mouse Theater, a nonviolent kids TV show on the local public access TV station. Job, of course, was the host of the program, Job playing Cockyboo the clown. Cockyboo is an old clown, dressed in rags that were once the clothes of a rich man, top hat and tuxedo coat. He's more scary than funny, and he's always trying to tell you something that you feel like you should be able to understand, but you can't.
1977年，约伯搬到亚利桑那州图森市，在那里加入了一群街头音乐家和表演者，他管理并将其组织成“魔术老鼠剧院”，这是一个在当地公共接入电视频道播放的非暴力儿童电视节目。约伯当然是节目的主持人，约伯扮演小丑Cockyboo。Cockyboo是一个老小丑，穿着曾是富人衣服的破布、礼帽和燕尾服。他看起来比好笑更可怕，而且他总是试图告诉你一些你觉得你应该能理解但实际上无法理解的事情。
It all started a long, long time ago. It was in a faraway place, close to the hearts of those knowing love. And there was a village called Angelville. Now, if you're going too fast or happened to sneeze, you wouldn't see it. And the only way one could get to Angelville was to find the secret path which led to the center of everything.
这一切开始于很久很久以前。是在一个遥远的地方，靠近那些懂得爱的人的心。有一个村庄叫天使村。现在，如果你开得太快或者正好打个喷嚏，你就看不见它了。而要去天使村的唯一方法，就是找到通往万物中心的那条秘密小径。
Job lives in a small adobe house he calls the Gandhi Peace Center, a shelter for homeless men. But the only homeless men here tonight seems to be Job Matusow. His bedroom is also the production room for the TV station, and it's crammed with blinking VCRs and scattered videocassettes and various dust-covered memorabilia from the past. It's dinner time, and Job is sitting on a sunken bed, feeding his five little dogs.
约伯住在一栋他称为“甘地和平中心”的小土屋里，那是无家可归男性的收容所。但今晚这里唯一的无家可归男性似乎就是约伯·马图索。他的卧室同时也是电视台的制作室，堆满了闪烁的录像机、散乱的录像带和过去各种蒙尘的纪念品。现在是晚餐时间，约伯坐在凹陷的床上，喂着他的五只小狗。
This is Mabel Muldoon. And this is Mopsy Muldoon. And this one is Buster Brown the Coolest Dog in Doggy Town. And they're my family. I like hanging out with dogs and people with disabilities.
这是梅布尔·马尔顿。这是莫普西·马尔顿。这一只是巴斯特·布朗，狗镇最酷的狗。它们是我的家人。我喜欢和狗以及有残疾的人在一起。
In order to achieve forgiveness, you must do three things. Of these three, the third, finding peace with yourself, is by far the most difficult. If you're able to do this, if you can find redemption, then when bad thing you did comes up again in memory or in conversation, it doesn't matter anymore, whether you were a victim a fate, or whether you caused it all to happen by your own conscious actions, whether you were just doing the best you could under the circumstances, or whether you were evil. When you have truly been forgiven, the bad thing doesn't have an effect on you anymore. It just goes right through you.
为了获得宽恕，你必须做三件事。在这三件事中，第三件——与自己达成和解——是最难的。如果你能做到这一点，如果你能获得救赎，那么当你做过的坏事再次在记忆或谈话中浮现时，它就不再重要了，无论你是命运的受害者，还是由于你自己的有意识行为导致这一切发生，无论你是在那种情况下尽力而为，还是你很邪恶。当你真正被宽恕后，那件坏事就不再对你有影响了。它只会直接穿过你。
Look, in the other room, I've got a big picture of Ray Cohn. It's a three-foot by five-foot photograph of Roy Cohn, big. Morton Downey, Jr., gave it to me one day in New York. And I put that picture up of Roy Cohn, that same picture, when he died on July 1, 1988. And I start to say a kaddish for him.
看，在另一个房间，我有一张罗伊·科恩的大照片。那是一张三英尺乘五英尺的罗伊·科恩的照片，很大。莫顿·唐尼二世有一天在纽约给我的。1988年7月1日他去世时，我挂起了那张罗伊·科恩的照片，同一张照片。我开始为他诵读犹太悼词。
And I don't let his spirit go, and he's the man I should be hating the most in the world. He sent me to jail for five years, and he was a miserable human being to a lot of people and did a lot of harm, much more than I ever did. And I still pray for the man. And his big picture's up in my studio, because I don't want to forget that I can forgive.
我没有让他的灵魂离去，他是我世界上最应该憎恨的人。他把我送进监狱五年，他对很多人来说都是个悲惨的人，造成了很大的伤害，比我造成的多得多。但我仍然为他祈祷。他的大照片挂在我的工作室里，因为我不想忘记我能够宽恕。
The most enjoyable time I have in life right now is when I sometimes have to get in my car at 4:30 or 5:00 in the morning here in central Utah and drive the 175 miles to Salt Lake City. And it's still dark, and I get in the car, and it's high in the mountains. And when I get in the car, I have a prayer, and then I start to conjure up the spirit of every human being I have ever known who has gone to spirit, starting with my parents, and my brother, and my aunts, and my uncles, and my grandparents, and then all the people I've ever known, including Senator Joseph McCarthy-- 44 uncles and aunts, including Roy Cohn, my countless cousins, and then all the friends and people I've known in my life who have gone to spirit.
我现在生命中最享受的时间，是偶尔在犹他州中部凌晨4点半或5点，开车行驶175英里去盐湖城的时候。天还是黑的，我上车，车在高高的山上。当我上车时，我先做一个祈祷，然后我开始召唤我所认识的每一个已经离世的人的灵魂，从我的父母开始，然后是我哥哥、我的阿姨、我的叔叔、我的祖父母，然后是我认识的所有人，包括约瑟夫·麦卡锡参议员——44个叔叔阿姨，包括罗伊·科恩，我无数的表亲，然后是我生命中认识的所有已经离世的朋友和人。
Job told me this story in his house. He told me the same story in his car.
约伯在他的家里告诉了我这个故事。他在车里又告诉我一次。
And I take a quiet moment and I say to each one, good morning, I love you, and you're not forgotten. I've never told this story to anybody before. Scott, this is amazing that I've shared this with you. It's a very private thing. But I want to state that, when I think of all the people, that means all the people I ever knew, the saints and the sinners, and sometimes especially the sinners.
我会安静片刻，对每一个人说，早上好，我爱你，你没有被遗忘。我以前从没对任何人讲过这个故事。斯科特，你能分享这些真是太神奇了。这是一件非常私密的事情。但我想要说明的是，当我想到所有人时，那意味着我认识的所有人，圣人和罪人，有时甚至是特别指那些罪人。
Reporter Scott Carrier lives in Salt Lake City.
记者斯科特·卡里尔住在盐湖城。
Act Two, God of War. This is the story about somebody who, like Job Matusow, had power over people's lives, thanks to a convergence of historical forces. But unlike Job Matusow, this man made a decision about what he thought about his role in history, at the time that it all happened. And he hasn't wavered much about it since.
第二幕，《战神》。这是一个关于某人的故事，他和约伯·马图索一样，由于历史力量的汇聚，对人们的生活拥有权力。但与约伯·马图索不同的是，这个人在事情发生时，就他对自己在历史中的角色做出了决定。从那以后，他在这方面并没有动摇多少。
It has taken a kind of toll on him, though. Jeffrey Harris served as a kind of psychologist for the Army during the Vietnam War, even though he had no graduate degree in psychology. It was his job to decide who could go home and who had to stay at the front. In other words, who might die and who might have a chance at living. He only had one year of grad school. His tour of duty began at Chu Lai.
不过，这对他造成了一定的伤害。杰弗里·哈里斯在越战期间担任军队的心理学家，尽管他没有心理学研究生学位。他的工作是决定谁可以回家，谁必须留在前线。换句话说，谁可能会死，谁还有活下去的机会。他只有一年的研究生经历。他的服役期始于朱莱。
It's right on the South China Sea. We had a beach right there. So we were kind of on the beach, and fairly far away from the perimeter. It's fairly safe. We'd get rockets in periodically that'd make you run for cover, but anything that hit over where we were was going to be stray because they'd generally aim their rockets at the airfield.
它就在南中国海边。我们那里有个海滩。所以我们基本上就在海滩上，离防线很远。相当安全。我们偶尔会遭到火箭弹袭击，让你不得不跑去躲避，但任何射到我们那边的东西都是流弹，因为他们的火箭一般瞄准的是机场。
I told my wife, I'm going to go over there and I'm going to stay as safe as possible and try to make it through the year and come back. That's what I want to do. That all changed after I got there. I mean, first place you start seeing people coming in out of the field, and it's hard not to identify with the war in some sense.
我告诉妻子，我要去那边，我会尽量保持安全，撑过这一年回来。这就是我想做的。但在我到那儿之后，一切都变了。我的意思是，首先你开始看到人们从战场上下来，很难不对战争产生某种共鸣。
So what do you mean, identify with the war?
你说的“对战争产生共鸣”是什么意思？
Well, there's a certain excitement to it. And if you're back in the rear, back someplace going through somewhat meaningless kind of procedures, you know, just practicing rote, over and over and over again, field training exercises, war games, and all the other stuff that you do, you know, inspection, shining your boots, marching, then the things that are going on are going on out there. I'll give you an example. The commanding officer of that company decided that he was going to beautify the place. He was going to plant palm trees and put in sidewalks. You know, you've got to get out there and do this.
嗯，它有一种兴奋感。如果你在后方，在某个地方进行一些毫无意义的程序，你知道，只是机械地一遍又一遍地练习，野战训练演习，战争游戏，还有你做的所有其他事情，你知道，检查，擦亮靴子，行军，而真正发生的事情都在外面。我给你举个例子。该公司的指挥官决定他要美化这个地方。他要种棕榈树，铺人行道。你知道，你必须到外面去做这些事。
Many soldiers volunteer. If they're in a safe place, it's not uncommon to volunteer to out where the action is, to get away from the bull [BLEEP] at the rear. The captain invites me into his little office and he says, we have a situation and we need a volunteer. You know, we considered the other social work specialists around here, but we figure you're the most qualified, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
许多士兵会自愿参加。如果他们在安全的地方，自愿去有战斗的地方并不罕见，为了逃避后方那些[哔——]事。上尉请我进他的小办公室，说，我们有一个情况，我们需要一名志愿者。你知道，我们考虑过这里的其他社会工作专家，但我们认为你是最合格的，等等，等等，等等。
And I said, what the hell are you asking me to volunteer for? Now, remember, I'm in Chu Lai, out on the beach. We'd go down there and drink beer and swim, the other kinds of things you do in Vietnam, sit there and smoke a joint and watch the moon rise. It's kind of a nice place. And I said, what are you asking me to volunteer for? And he says, well, the 196th Infantry Brigade is going away. And it was at that time-- I don't know whether you remember-- but it was when the siege on Hue was taking place. This was right after the Tet Offensive.
我说，你到底要我志愿去干什么？现在，记住，我在朱莱，在海滩上。我们会去那里喝啤酒游泳，在越南还会做其他事情，坐在那里抽根烟，看月亮升起。那是个不错的地方。我说，你要求我志愿做什么？他说，好吧，第196步兵旅要走了。当时——我不知道你是否记得——正是顺化围城发生的时候。这就在春节攻势之后。
In fact, it's the setting for Full Metal Jacket . He says, 196th is going away, and we'd like you to go with them. And my stomach just went [MAKES PLOPPING SOUND]. And I'm sitting there looking at this guy. And so what I finally did, I got to use the-- Actually, the thing that ended up getting me out in the field was I couldn't pass up a good one liner. I turned to him and I said, yeah, I've been wanting to get out of this chicken [BLEEP] anyway.
事实上，这是《全金属外壳》的背景。他说，196旅要走了，我们希望你和他们一起去。我的胃当时就“噗通”响了一下。我坐在那儿看着这家伙。所以我最后做的是，我不得不使用——其实，最终让我到前线去的是我无法放过一句好的俏皮话。我转过身对他说，是啊，我一直都想离开这个鸡[哔——]地方。
And I couldn't pass up the one-liner. You know, it was one of those mixed feelings. Did I want to go through this whole situation and someday my grandkids come out and say, grandpa, were you in the war? Yeah. What did you do? Planted palm trees.
我无法放过那句俏皮话。你知道，那是种混合的情绪。我是想经历这一切，有一天我的孙子们出来问，爷爷，你参加过战争吗？是的。你做了什么？种棕榈树。
Furthermore, they were right. I mean, when he said, you're the most qualified, he was right. I conceivably was-- well, I was. I was the most qualified there, and I knew that. Even though I didn't know what the hell I was doing, I knew none of us did. So I went.
此外，他们是对的。我的意思是，当他说“你是最合格的”时，他是对的。我确实——好吧，我就是。我是那里最合格的，我知道。尽管我根本不知道自己在做什么，但我知道我们谁都不知道。所以我去了。
I am out with a medical unit. And we have our own little kind of a hospital to handle incoming casualties, which could either be some sort of physical casualty or psychiatric casualty. And I have to give you an idea of what our hospital looked like. The hospital that we'd worked in was built out of ammo boxes that were filled with sand-- that was the walls-- and a plywood kind of a roof over this thing. That was basically it. Plywood floor.
我在一个医疗小组。我们有我们自己的那种医院来处理送进来的伤员，可能是某种身体伤害或心理伤害。我必须让你对我们的医院有个概念。我们工作的医院是用装满沙子的弹药箱建造的——那是墙壁——上面盖着胶合板屋顶。基本上就是这样。胶合板地板。
What the equivalent of a bed was a stretcher. What you had was like saw horses set up, and the casualties would come in on stretchers and you'd lay the stretchers over the saw horses. That's essentially what the hospital looked like.
床的等价物是担架。你看到的是支架，伤员躺在担架上被送进来，你把担架放在支架上。这就是医院基本上看起来的样子。
And I am the only-- what would you call it? I'm the only thing close to a psychologist they've got, even though I'm only an enlisted man. And it was frightening for me. It was very scary for me. They're going to tell me, this individual is yours, and you've got to deal with it, when my background was essentially running rats around mazes. And what in the hell am I doing here?
我是唯一的——你叫它什么？我是他们那里唯一接近心理学家的人，尽管我只是个士兵。这让我感到害怕。对我来说非常恐怖。他们要告诉我，这个人归你了，你得处理它，而我的背景基本上是在迷宫里跑老鼠。我到底在这儿干什么？
And often, when we get casualties, one out of four would be psychiatric. So I was dealing one out of-- 25% often would be-- And they'd say, Harris, he's yours. Take what used to be called combat fatigue. That term was not used in Vietnam. It has been used previously. Shell-shocked is another term. It's the notion of somebody situationally that has reacted to a very high-stress situation, and in some sense or another, broken down. That was a common sort of thing that I had to deal with.
而且通常，当我们收到伤员时，四分之一是心理上的。所以我处理的四分之一的人往往是……他们会说，哈里斯，他归你了。处理过去被称为“战斗疲劳”的症状。那个词在越南没用过。它以前被用过。“弹震症”是另一个词。这是一种身处高压环境、在某种意义上崩溃的状况。那是我必须处理的一种常见事情。
You weren't looking at psychotic behavior. You weren't looking at somebody that was having delusions or hallucinations. You were looking at someone that's basically in sort of a major panic attack. Sometimes it was. You'd see panic attacks. But kind of a breakdown and a return to sort of a childishness, help me, help me. I can't handle myself. I can't handle this. I'm weak. And crying, crying to become-- How can I put it? Somebody to help them, somebody to save them. And given the situations that they were in, it's quite understandable. They might have been walking along and all of a sudden, their whole unit's gone and they're there.
你面对的不是精神病行为。你面对的不是那些有幻觉或妄想的人。你面对的是一个基本上处于严重恐慌发作中的人。有时确实是。你会看到惊恐发作。但更像是崩溃和回归到某种幼稚状态，帮帮我，帮帮我。我无法控制自己。我无法应付这个。我很虚弱。又哭又闹，变得——我该怎么说呢？需要人帮他们，需要人救他们。考虑到他们所处的环境，这是完全可以理解的。他们可能走着走着，突然整个单位都没了，而他们还留在那里。
They wanted me to state that they were psychiatrically, in some constitutional way, unable to go back into that kind of situation, that they had to be removed from the danger because there was something wrong with them. They're saying that they can't do it. They may not be saying that explicitly, but the body language and the language and everything implied that. And furthermore, quite often it was quite explicit. I can't go back out there. I can't do it. I'll break down. I'll die. I'm unable to do this. I'm not strong enough.
他们想让我证明他们在心理上、某种体质上无法回到那种情况中，他们必须被带离危险，因为他们出了什么问题。他们在说他们做不到。他们可能没有明确说出来，但肢体语言和语言暗示了一切。而且此外，经常非常明确。我不能再回去了。我做不到。我会崩溃的。我会死的。我没法做这个。我不够坚强。
I mean, you can play with the theory theoretically yourself. What happens to somebody when you turn to them, and they say, I'm too weak, I can't handle this kind of situation. Other people can handle stress, other people can handle danger, I can't. And I turn to them and I agree, and I say, that's right, that's the kind of person you are.
我的意思是，你可以自己在理论上推演一下。当有人对你说，我太弱了，我无法应付这种局面时，会发生什么。其他人能应对压力，其他人能应对危险，我不行。我转过头去同意他们，我说，那是对的，你就是那样的人。
So I didn't say that. I placed the responsibility back on them, that they've got to make a choice, that I am not going to tell them that they're too weak, or that they're too incapable of handling stress, that there's something constitutionally or genetically or whatever the hell it is wrong with them that makes them different from other people. And also that the reaction is a human reaction, and conceivably it could happen to anybody, any of us.
所以我没那样说。我把责任放回他们身上，说他们必须做出选择，我说我不会告诉他们太弱了，或者无法应对压力，不是他们体质上或基因上或其他什么该死的有问题，使得他们与众不同。而且我也说，这是一种人类的反应，想象一下，这可能发生在任何人身上，我们任何一个人身上。
And my rule was basically none of us go home unless we all go home. And so, for the combat fatigue or acute situational reaction, the response was that, you are going back to your unit. I'm not going to take you out. I'm not going to give you a diagnosis and tell you-- I'm not going to send you back to a hospital on the basis that there's something psychologically wrong with you.
我的原则基本上是，除非我们都能回家，否则谁也不回家。所以，对于战斗疲劳或急性情境反应，回答就是：你必须回到你的单位。我不会把你带走。我不会给出诊断告诉你——我不会因为你有什么心理问题就把你送回医院。
And it's a simple philosophy. If you fall of the horse, you get back on. You go back into the situation and you deal with. Now, the individual, they'll say, I can't. I'll say, well, you've got a choice. You can go back to your unit commander and refuse. Well, they'll throw me in the stockade. I say, that's a possibility. Another possibility is that they'll send you back to the rear and have you folding blankets in some supply room. I don't know what they'll do. But I'm not going to make the decision. You've got to make a decision.
这是一个简单的哲学。如果你从马上掉下来，你就得再爬上去。你回到那个情境中去处理它。现在，那个人会说，我不能。我会说，好吧，你有选择。你可以回到你的单位指挥官那里拒绝。好吧，他们会把我关进禁闭室。我说，那是一种可能。另一种可能是他们会把你送回后方，让你在供应室叠毛毯。我不知道他们会做什么。但我不会做那个决定。你必须做出决定。
Do I sound like it was not difficult for me? Quite often, I could've pulled people back, sent them back to the rear. I could have done a number of things. I had the power to do that, even though I was only an enlisted man. I was the only one they had. And I had that kind of power, and it was very frightening for me. It was something that I had never planned on. I had never taken that kind of responsibility in my life, and had never planned on taking it.
我听起来像是不困难吗？经常，我本可以把人拉回来，送回后方。我可以做很多事。我有权那样做，尽管我只是个士兵。我是他们唯一的选择。我有那种权力，这让我非常害怕。那是我从未计划过的。我一生中从未承担过那种责任，也从未计划过。
And there is sense in which you do become inert. You're able to look at something and say, oh, there it is. You look at something gruesome. That was a common expression in Vietnam-- There it is. You walk up on somebody and he's got his head blown off and his guts are all over, and people look at it and say, there it is, and walk on.
在某种意义上，你确实变得麻木了。你能够看着某样东西说，哦，就是这样。你看着恐怖的东西。那是越南常见的一种表达——“就是这样”。你走到某人面前，发现他的头被炸飞了，内脏到处都是，人们看着它说，就是这样，然后走开。
How else do you deal with sort of thing? What do you say? You say, there it is. So you do develop a defense, which for me was kind of frightening after I realized I had it. After I came back from Vietnam, that was part of a change that had occurred to me that I was not sure that I wanted to maintain, was this being able to emotionally distance myself from pain, from somebody else's pain. At the same time, I don't want to give it up.
你还能怎么处理那种事？你说什么？你说，就是这样。所以你确实形成了一种防御，这对我来说在意识到我有这种防御后是相当恐怖的。从越南回来后，那是我发生改变的一部分，我不确定我是否想保持这种能够从痛苦、从别人的痛苦中情感疏离的能力。同时，我不想放弃它。
Dr. Jeffrey Harris is now a psychologist practicing in Salt Lake City. He spoke with Scott Carrier.
杰弗里·哈里斯博士现在是盐湖城的一名执业心理学家。他与斯科特·卡里尔交谈过。
Well, our program produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Senior editor Paul Tough. Contributing editors, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Rachel Day and [? Suyuni ?] Davenport. "That's The Way It Is" was played on acoustic guitar for us by Michael Kirkpatrick.
今天我们的节目是由阿丽克斯·斯皮格尔和我制作的，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德协助。高级编辑保罗·塔夫。特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作协助来自雷切尔·戴和[？]达文波特。迈克尔·柯克帕特里克为我们用原声吉他演奏了《事情就是这样》。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you want to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at the WBEZ in Chicago. The phone number, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
如果您想购买本节目的录音带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ。电话号码是312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是 [email protected]。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助商致谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who also describes himself as--
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚，他也这样描述自己——
The person who started the myth about getting high off smoking banana peels.
那个传出吸食香蕉皮能产生快感谣言的人。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带给大家更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。